en un vídeo anterior hablamos sobre el
concepto de función de producción
agregada la cual es una forma elegante
para referirnos a un modelo matemático
que usan los economistas para relacionar
los factores de producción con la
producción agregada de una economía la
producción agregada la definimos con la
letra g mayúscula y los factores de
producción que ya hemos mencionado antes
son el capital humano la tecnología el
capital no humano entre otros en esta
fórmula representa el factor tecnológico
y se le conoce como productividad total
de los factores cada se refiere al
capital no humano aunque normalmente se
usa la letra c para referirse al capital
pero aquí se usó acá la letra l se
refiere al capital humano que podríamos
pensarlo como la mano de obra pero en
realidad se refiere a algo más que eso
más adelante veremos esto con mayor
detalle para comprender mejor esto que
está en una anotación de función en
general es decir que solo se denota que
es una función de acá y l y puede verse
muy abstracto vamos a analizar un
ejemplo de este tipo de funciones en
este ejemplo la producción agregada es
igual a la productividad total de los
factores que recordemos mide la
tecnología x el capital elevado a cierta
potencia multiplicado por el capital
humano elevado a cierta potencia en los
cursos de introducción a la economía no
tenemos que realizar este tipo de
cálculos con elementos elevados a
exponentes fraccionarios aunque tenemos
muchos vídeos en khan academy donde
explicamos cómo calcular este tipo de
exponentes pero nos da una idea de que
si alguno de estos elementos se
incrementa entonces se espera que la
producción agregada también se
incremente y si por alguna razón alguno
de estos factores disminuye entonces
tendrá un impacto negativo en la
producción agregada en este vídeo nos
vamos a enfocar en cómo se pueden
calcular valores para estos factores en
una economía cómo podemos encontrar los
valores para acá y el pausa en el vídeo
y piensen en esto comencemos con el
factor l que podríamos ver como mano de
obra pero que en realidad se refiere al
capital humano cómo se mide el capital
humano bueno una forma de hacer esto es
medir la mano de obra
y cómo se mide la mano de obra pues una
forma sería ver cuántas personas se
encuentran en la fuerza laboral
trabajando pero esto es lo único que nos
interesa de la mano de obra pues no ya
que no todos los trabajadores son
iguales las personas enfermas no pueden
producir lo mismo que las personas sanas
las personas que no tienen una buena
capacitación no podrán producir mucho
así que no se trata de ver solamente
cuántas personas están trabajando en
cierta economía sino que también importa
la educación y la capacitación que
tengan estas personas mientras más
educación y capacitación tengan las
personas que trabajan más valdrá l
mientras más personas sanas estén
trabajando más aumenta l así como mayor
sea la cantidad de personas que estén
trabajando más valdrá l ya que estas
personas podrán producir más como se
mide que el capital físico de una
economía quizá podríamos pensar en
contar la cantidad de capital que tiene
esa economía pero esto no tendría
sentido ya que algunos elementos del
capital pueden ser herramientas y otros
pueden ser edificios o trenes así que
los economistas miden que en términos
del valor
el capital de cierta economía acá es el
valor del capital en una economía pero
lo interesante aquí es ver cómo se mide
a pues no existe un índice específico
obvio para medir la tecnología de una
economía no podemos solamente observar y
decir que una economía tiene más
tecnología que otra por lo que los
economistas miden como un mecanismo de
ajuste en esta fórmula podemos encontrar
él podemos encontrar acá y sabemos que
la producción agregada es el pib real de
esa economía y así que si dos economías
tienen el mismo valor de l y el mismo
valor de acá pero su pib ya es diferente
entonces quiere decir que tienen una
diferente podemos ver a casi como un
ajuste para compensar la diferencia
entre kl y pero sería la medida de que
tan tecnológicamente avanzada es una
economía si nuestra economía tiene una
que vale uno y otra economía tiene una
que vale dos entonces quiere decir que
la otra economía tiene el doble de
productividad siempre y cuando los
valores de acá
es el capital no humano y dl que es el
capital humano sean los mismos que los
de nuestra economía esto implica que la
otra economía tiene el doble de
tecnología que la nuestra con esto
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo